avec dans notre chambre le nouveau
président américain on est vraiment en
territoire complètement inconnu ce n'est
pas un politicien professionnel
c'est un homme d'affaires milliardaire
qui a fait fortune dans l'immobilier
il a promis de faire les choses
autrement et si ce qu'il va faire il a
réinventé la façon de faire la politique
et il va probablement aussi réinventer
la façon de gouverner ce que l'on peut
vous dire pour l'instant c'est que une
des premières choses que dans notre
chambre veut faire lorsqu'il mettra les
pieds à la maison blanche le 20 janvier
prochain
c'est d'abolir obamacare ce vaste
système d'assurance santé qui a permis à
20 millions d'américains de plus d'avoir
une couverture médicale dans notre
chambre veut complètement l'abolir et le
remplacer par un autre système mais ça
n'a pas encore été précisé de quelle
manière il veut remplacer obama qu'hier
il a l'intention aussi de construire un
mur entre le mexique et les etats-unis
pour prévenir l'immigration illégale
il veut également des portes et les
criminels qui ont passé judiciaire un
passé criminel aux états unis et il a
également l'intention de créer 25
millions d'emplois on le voit dans notre
combat a promis ces emplois aux
américains du michigan luis concerne la
pennsylvanie des états qui lui ont donné
la victoire
alors ce sera très important pour lui au
cours de son mandat de continuer à
parler à ces gens et surtout de tenir
promesse pour leur apporter des emplois
des emplois plus payant sur la scène
internationale c'est un peu moins clair
ce qu'il veut faire son plein à
politique étrangère n'a pas encore été
très très détaillé ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'ils veulent se rapprocher avec
la russie il veut faire la vie un peu
plus dur à la chine il veut également
être beaucoup plus près d'israël il veut
renégocier des ententes de libre-échange
entre autres l'alena dont fait partie le
canada
alors on verra de quelle manière tout ça
va s'articuler au cours des prochains
mois et pour ce faire il a mis en place
une équipe d'hommes et de femmes avec
des profils assez particulier tout
d'abord pour la plupart ce sont des
millionnaires voire des milliers
hors d'air et certains d'entre eux sont
carrément de par leur idéologie
de par leur passé leur façon de penser à
en porte à faux avec le département qui
s'apprête à diriger on parle de la
secrétaire à l'éducation
betty devos qui est contre l'école
publique le nouveau patron de lippi et
la grande agence environnementale qui
protègent l'environnement aux états unis
ce cap rude qui lui est un climato
sceptiques et en terminant rick perry
secrétaire à l'énergie qui a dit
publiquement qu'il avait l'intention
d'abolir le département de l'énergie
qu'il va maintenant diriger alors dans
notre champ que nous réserve beaucoup de
surprises au cours des prochains mois au
cours des prochaines années
et avant de dire que sa présidence sera
un échec ou une réussite
il faudra attendre de voir de quelle
manière il va ils vont implanter ses
réformes et où il amènera les états unis
[Musique]